rosie brooks has been a doctor for
almost 25 years in that time the nhs has
faced many challenges but things are so
bad now that she's leaving general
practice it's never been easy the job is
tough
but this is on another scale
if you can't ever feel you switch off if
you constantly worry if you wake up
worrying and people say oh well you just
need to manage it better
i'm i'm a
very capable person but now there's just
it's just the numbers are too
overwhelming for the numbers that we are
here
the surgery lost three doctors last year
and found it hard to fill the vacancies
a symptom of a struggling health service
the pressure isn't just being felt in gp
surgeries like this one it's been felt
right the way through
the nhs and the pandemic although it's
made things much worse well that
pressure has been building for some time
a damning report by cross-party mps
warns patients lives are being put at
risk
the report shows the nhs in england is
short of 12 000 hospital doctors and
over 50 000 nurses and midwives
as of september last year the nhs was
advertising for almost 100 000 vacant
posts and a similar number for social
care projections suggest almost half a
million jobs will be needed in health
and even more than that in social care
in the coming years
it's not just about money you can put 12
billion a year or 10 billion a year as
it actually will end up being into the
nhs but if you haven't got to 10 billion
bids worth of extra doctors and nurses
if you haven't got the capacity in the
system
you won't get the extra operations that
you need and so that's what we're saying
needs to happen now
the report is highly critical of the
government saying it has failed to act
decisively but the department of health
and social care says it is committed to
recruiting thousands of extra doctors
and nurses and is developing a long-term
workforce plan nurses moment are are
tired they're they're over stretched
they've gone through a challenging few
few years and all of that now is
actually pushing us out of the
profession the nhs is much more than
just buildings and beds it's the it's
the people in the building
the nhs workforce crisis is growing as
it does
long-suffering patients will have to
wait longer
and suffer more
joshi sky news west london